[Music]
[Applause]
program
he's the host of the sean salisbury show
every morning monday through friday on
sports talk 790 in houston
sean i've mentioned uh the last two
hours i'm not going to litigate this
this
isn't about i'm not court tv this is
just
me in my level of expertise is the
football aspect of desean watson
and where the houston texans are so we
appreciate you joining us and
um i i hope you understand how i'm
coming at this i don't care
you know how salacious the details are
the allegations are serious here
but uh what is the mood what do you
think what's the local reaction here in
houston with what's going on with
deshawn watson
yeah dan and i'm with you you know the
irresponsibility that goes with i don't
know
and this is about the sports part
because it's a very sensitive serious
situation for both sides and
and they all deserve due process dan
it's a very
well if you want uh controversy and
stuff that's going on houston seems to
be the place to find it the last
year and a half when it comes to sports
and this is obviously to another level
of seriousness um
yeah i i there's a there's a mixed and
there's a
like we're talking about when it comes
to the legality of it
of letting due process take but when it
comes to the sports process of
you know there's conspiracy theories and
there's what are the texans going to do
now or
was this plan you hear it all and now if
you were a team that was interested in
deshawn were a team
was it that was interested in deshaun
watson are you still um
are the texans now putting themselves in
position where the value of him goes
down what's going to happen with the
commissioner
there is a very they've been very
sensitive here
and it's like the the fans here and the
local talk here is
hard to fathom knowing what you you know
going into this
just six months ago he had signed a new
contract and he was the
you know the darling of this town and
obviously still deserves due process but
it's i think it's more gut-wrenching
than anything that people can't believe
they're in this position
whether it's true or whether it's not
down i know the texans have said
publicly they're not trading him
and they're not uh entertaining offers
do you think the texans have entertained
offers on desean watson
i do and i don't that's just my opinion
dan and haven't been in this business
in the sports business and seen it for a
long time um
they'd be stupid not to i'm talking
about this is pre all this
even with this to not take calls why
wouldn't you you you always
the phone i'm answering the phone no
matter what now i understand desean
watson the player is
phenomenal and it would take a hall to
get him
but why wouldn't you take calls on the
did it's your business
um you got to do what's best for your
team if somebody wanted calling off your
six first rounders you got to listen so
i do believe in my heart
whether they're serious in accepting
them or going to trade him i understand
why they'd want to draw a line in the
sand and say listen we're not trading
this guy is
a big time asset in the league as a
football player but i also know
in my mind that you'd be an idiot not to
take calls on a guy
and just file them away considering you
may get one that you just can't turn
down so i believe in my heart while they
may tell us one thing
that they're taking because that's a
good business move to take calls on an
asset like desean
how much credibility has he built up in
the city
prior to all of this how was desean
watson viewed on and off the field
biggest star in the town dan i mean off
the field
a charitable guy cared involved in now
you know like some of the restaurant
stuff he was held in the highest regard
you could hold a player in this town
i mean in the past you know elijah won
has been held such high regard there's
been so many that have come through here
he was a guy that
basically could do no wrong and dan when
this first started about him not wanting
to play here
it was like every 98 of their damn near
100 of the people i talked to were all
all watson all the time right now i
don't know how that's changed with this
on the perception not the nobody's
guilty yet but on the perception of it
but i have heard more whispers you know
on my show of people calling in
and saying man i started out deshawn can
do no wrong but now as they continue to
come out that
it makes like anybody say well what
happened here how did it get to this
point
um on both sides so but dan
he and there's people that are gonna and
as we should let due process
take its course but this guy was held
just as you can imagine somebody in
other cities around the country
their star desean watson was that guy to
this city
and in many points for some people still
is at least even the last few days of
people that have called in my show
who runs this franchise like who is the
person that's in charge of everything
if i had money and had to bet it dan i
would say that the guy who's running
this franchise is
jack easterby i i would i i don't think
you're making many decisions that aren't
run by his destiny
i know what's his role uh well we don't
know he
came from a chaplain put it this way of
guys that are in his position of power
very few have had a resume as empty
to be in that position of power now i've
never met him
i'm always willing to give a guy benefit
out now you all these articles that have
come out on
the dysfunction in the franchise and
jack but i can't fathom with decisions
that have been made about personnel
not only players dan but people from you
know equipment staff
everything i don't believe now i think
nick casario is making a lot of these
football decisions
as he should because his resume says top
shelf and should be in this position
he should be the one making all the
decisions when it comes to football
but bill belichick's admit jack's not a
personnel guy and i think cal mcnair has
but he's a former team chaplain yes
right yes
yeah yes he is and a character coach but
he has found a way in this thing just
from our my knowledge and
the way people are talking and things
i've read and heard
that but there's very few things that
are going by
or decisions that are being made on
anything in that building
that jack doesn't have insight in so i
actually think while cal
signs the paychecks i think jack's
making most of the decisions and they're
letting nick do the football stuff
but i don't believe nick's making
football decisions just based on here's
what i want
i think you're clearing everything and
if deshawn watson were to stay or get
traded no matter
where this goes dan i i think that jack
easterbee would be a guy who's going to
have a lot of saying
there is the dysfunction and quite
frankly the
the the talk of a cultish feeling in the
building
is this is all pre all this stuff that's
going on now is part of it now there's
people who swear by jack easterbee
in his past but here he's become he's
become the guy that that people would
want out and i talked to a guy dan i
asked who would be
if you had to make the decision on
watson or easter be if cal mcnair had to
make that decision
pre-all this controversy he said he
believes that cal would choose jack
easter be over deshawn watson
pre-all this stuff happening he's uh
sean salisbury the morning host
sean salisbury show sports talk 790 in
houston a couple other football items
here arizona cardinals got older did
they get better
i do think so they got older but dan
something i know youth matters
but i also believe that that team's
lacking something it's just
with fits there it's helped obviously
keeping adding jj watt
you're adding character you're adding
guys who can may not give it to you for
the hudson the whole group i actually do
think they got better and if kyle murray
elevates his play
the i think that they're a definite
threat in the in the nfc
west the rams are good depending on what
happens with russ wilson
but i do think while older now dan
talked to me in five years
we'll have a different conversation but
in the urgent i don't think there's any
question
that locker room will feel different and
the performance will be better because
they will raise the energy these
veterans they've added
will raise the energy and performance of
some of these young players they did get
better
i know that the bears and seahawks
didn't want the information brought out
that i reported on
what they offered for russell wilson but
it is out there
i'm just curious though sean i don't
understand why the seahawks john
schneider will sit down with the bears
gm ryan pace
and listen to a trade offer as what
peter king said last hour well maybe
it's just uh you know
professional courtesy there okay
professional courtesy and you're gonna
listen to a trade offer for us or we'll
and then you don't counter anything like
so what was the purpose
of that that's the disrespect of it if
i'm gonna listen to your offer
professional courtesy don't i at least
owe you something
as a response back to you yeah i i made
an offer could you do these counters say
hey listen
could you add two more picks right dan
here's the wife like
i'm not there but my thought is the
reason why he's entertaining the offer
because they would be interested if it
was something they couldn't refuse now
i've all i've said you work your whole
career to find a guy like russ wilson or
deshaun watson or patrick mahomes
player why do i want to give him up only
to try and find it again
and the bears they haven't got that
quarterback position right
dan for forever forever and if you had a
chance to give up three ones and they
seattle would have taken it you jump all
over that russ wilson thing because
there's no guarantee with the picks but
yeah i i i personally think if i was
chicago you know what i do dan
i four like i call back and i say well
what if i added an another second round
pick
or added a second round pick to this or
another player and see if you could
actually get
or say oh you wanted me to counter of
course but dan to me
i would throw in andy dalton he just got
there i'd say
send the red rifle or the red pop gun or
the red cannon whatever you want to call
him
i'm with you offer what you want and can
you imagine though
what it instantly does for the bears if
russell wilson was in uniform for them
i get why seattle's not but i believe
like the texans if seattle got an offer
they couldn't refuse you have to
consider it
a counteroffer would be nice if you're
seattle and if you don't want her then
don't answer the phone and don't discuss
trades if you're not interested in
taking a trade
great to talk to you sean have a great
weekend and uh
strap in there yeah all day i got the
roller coaster double ride strap did by
the way you didn't want to talk final
four today dan
i thought that somebody brackets none of
that um
no who you got winning it real quick i
don't know
you don't no you're i've seen your jump
shot i got are you probably saving
i got an hour and a half before i have
to make it official oh
my bad that's right i'm cutting into
your your prediction late in the show
how are my houston cougars doing they're
really really good they're going they're
going to play illinois for a trip to the
final four
there you go kelvin sampson will have
them ready to play
okay and sean was a good basketball
player in high school
yeah yeah yeah it was
the fifth story no no but you were you
were what did you average
in in high school 26 and a half 25 and a
half
points okay i was physical though
nasty on the glass man mad hops all that
now you can see now i can't jump higher
you could slide a piece of paper under
my word
barely you were tyler hansbrough before
tyler hands row
i was i was the jack sigma
all right i like that i like that yeah
jack sickball of orange glitter high
school yeah
it's good to be home did i retire your
jersey in high school
uh my football jersey i i cannot believe
my baseball and basketball jersey aren't
hanging in there there's going to be a
problem
because that's as close to any other
jersey retirement i'll ever get other
than
possibly the winnipeg blue bombers maybe
maybe how many touchdown passes you
throw your senior year
i have no idea no clue i could tell you
how many points i scored footballs
dan i don't know i can't name eight
completions in high school
pro but i can tell you every jump shot
and dunk and and home run i hit
i can i don't know anything about
football maybe i want to forget it but
no you could be honest no no because you
look he went to usc you were one of the
more highly recruited quarterbacks in
the country yeah i mean
a long time ago yes
do we need to start a movement at uh
like escondido high
or wherever uh oh excuse me
orange orange gland high yeah orange
gland height
reggie bush was uh escondido right right
right right no
he was helix oh helix tiger bill yeah
bill walton and brian and i remind bill
walton all the time when i see him
that i passed him on the all-time san
diego county scoring list
okay and i did now i don't know who's
better the big red header of me and
as far as basketball in high school
probably probably walt disney okay
okay but yeah orange good paint we got
to start the ground swell's got to build
retire the basketball jersey
great to be on thank you sean i
appreciate you brother thank you that's
sean salisbury
and by the way i joke with sean all the
time sean was a great high school
quarterback
all-american went to usc